many people know that warren buffett's
been one of the best investors over the
last half century or so but most people
don't actually understand exactly how
he's made his money usually those young
people they just think that he picked
the best stocks or he happened to be in
the right place at the right time but
warren buffett actually is a highly
patient investor he waits for market
downturns and then he pounces have you
ever heard the saying be greedy when
others are fearful and fearful when
others are greedy that's basically
warren buffett's playbook go back to
2008 when all of a sudden the global
financial crisis was kicked off and the
banks were on their knees literally
everyone was wondering which banks will
survive and which ones will fail warren
buffett showed up to save the day take
goldman sachs as an example he put in 5
billion or so he ended up making about 3
billion when he went and made that bet
and so naturally you can think of warren
buffett as somebody who capitalizes on
market downturn when other people are
needy he's there to save them now that
begs the question sam bankman freed the
founder of ftx and alameda research is
he the warren buffett of crypto well
just in the last week or so we've seen
ftx and alameda step in and help a
number of different firms they extended
a 200 million dollar credit line to
voyager they extended a 250 million
dollar credit line to blockfox ftx just
announced the acquisition of inbed a
finra regulated clearinghouse that's
going to help ftx with all of their
stock trading features and functionality
and so ultimately is somebody the warren
buffett of crypto or not it's kind of
hard to tell somewhat subjective but
what we do see is that sam bankman freed
ftx and alameda they have strong balance
sheets they've got great cash flow and
they are trying to capitalize on the
market downturn we've seen bitcoin's
price drop by 70 percent many of the
altcoins are down even more than that
but sam bakeman freed and his companies
they're stepping in they're trying to
prevent more contagion from spreading
throughout the industry they're trying
to plug holes and they're trying to stop
the freefall of asset prices ultimately
we don't have a crystal ball and we
don't know whether these bets will work
out or not but if we take warren buffett
and the whole value investing approach
being greedy when others are fearful and
we apply it to crypto there's no one who
seems to fit that narrative more than
sam bakeman free and so if these bets
work out and we look back five or ten
years from now and we say
so many people were fearful that was
near the bottom of the market and sam
ftx and alameda they stepped in with a
lot of capital and they were able to
capitalize during those fearful times i
think more and more people will start to
say sam and warren may have more in
common than you would have thought hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time